berlin die stadt die wächst an jeder
ecke wird gebaut
40.000 neuberliner jedes jahr mehr
kaufen will muss tief in die tasche
greifen die quadratmeterpreise haben
sich in den letzten zehn jahren
verdoppelt
ein preistreiber immer mehr luxus
appartements im stadtzentrum
diese terrasse gehört zu einer 90
quadratmeter wohnung verkauft für
700.000 euro die künftigen bewohner
freuen sich auf den umzug sind aber auch
nachdenklich
statt weniger interessant wird das so
ein bisschen die die kunstszene und die
die kreativszene ein bisschen
zurückgedrängt werden weil die mieten
steigen ist so dass die leute die wenig
einkommen haben das nicht mehr bezahlen
können das macht ein bisschen sorge dass
berlin sich so hinkel hin entwickelt zu
einer sehr teuren stadt dir nicht mehr
so interessant ist im zentrum des
streits die altbauten wie schnell und
wie hoch dürfen die mieten steigen nach
einer teuren sanierung in diesem haus
sind fast alle mieter raus
bis auf eine wohngemeinschaft sie hat
geklagt die sanierung sei teurer als
nötig und hätte ihre miete verdreifacht
die folge räumungsklagen und nervenkrieg
mit dem eigentümer noch immer laufen
gerichtsverfahren ist eine mieterstadt
es gibt ein schutz dafür es gibt darauf
ein recht und da kommt niemand daher und
kauft einfach und schmeißt mit solchen
methoden raus es brodelt in der stadt
die auseinandersetzung zwischen
eigentümern und mietern verschärft sich
es gibt zwangsräumungen polizeieinsätze
demos und die berliner diskutieren wem
gehört eigentlich ihre stadt ein kleiner
teil gehört ihm
jakob mehreren der berliner startete vor
15 jahren im immobiliengeschäft mit
einer wohnung heute sind es mehr als
2000 und deren wert steigt weiter
die mieter betonte sind für ihn keine
gegner sondern partner
unser geschäftsmodell basiert nicht auf
dass wir den mieter rauswerfen und
und dann verkaufen sondern im gegenteil
die mieter könnten wir dieses geschäft
nicht betreiben in der regel tun wir was
für den mieter wieder entwickelndes haus
wir machen eigentlich das gesamtobjekt
wohnlicher ja und wenn weniger geklärt
stand hat oder auch leerstand bekommt
weil fachleute kündigen oder ausziehen
sanieren wenn der regel die wohnungen
wenn sie im unsanierten zustand sind und
vermieten diese dann neu in der regel
wenn wir geld investieren wird's teurer
klar die mieten in berlin sind rasant
gestiegen um über 50 prozent in den
letzten fünf jahren auf durchschnittlich
zehn euro pro quadratmeter
geht das so weiter dass sich die mieter
fürchten vor einer entwicklung wie sie
in den letzten jahren war ich glaube da
kann ich mir ein bisschen die angst
nehmen also dass meine persönliche
vermutung ich glaube dass nach wie vor
sich der berliner markt entwickelt
sowohl das kaufpreise angeht auch mieten
aber eben nicht in der geschwindigkeit
der letzten jahr trotzdem bei den
berliner mietern ist das misstrauen groß
dieses haus sollte verkauft werden
an wen sagte man den mieter nicht sie
hatten angst um ihr zuhause und fanden
eine ungewöhnliche lösung selbst kaufen
die idee ist quasi das nicht also dass
uns das haus als kollektiv gehört und
wir alle aber weiterhin miete zahlen
aber geringe mieten und garantiert
geringe mieten damit leben bleiben
können dass es sozusagen unser ziel die
idee kommt vom sogenannten mietshäuser
syndikat das hilft auch dabei mehr als
zwei millionen euro aufzutreiben
wir als mietshäuser syndikat haben gute
kontakte zu banken und stiftungen die
grundfertigkeiten fremdkapital
finanzieren können also in hausbruch 80
prozent fremdkapital das heißt also die
größte summe kommt von der bank
trotzdem kein hauskauf ohne eigenkapital
damit aus den mietern eigentümer werden
müssen sie viel geld beschafft
hier müssen etwa 4000 euro dafür
darüber aufgebracht werden und diese
4000 euro kommen über viele kleinere
kredite zusammen sind kredite im
allgemeinen die zwischen 1000 und
fünfter
euro liegen von den leuten selber von
freunden und bekannten gehört das haus
erst ihnen stehen die bewohner vor ganz
ungewohnten fragen
damit das projekt sich rechnet müssen
sie sich selbst die miete erhöhen
wie funktioniert das das funktioniert so
dass wir als auch das versuchen in der
gemeinschaft zu entscheiden hat also wir
treffen uns zum beispiel unten im hof
trinken was grillen und diskutieren halt
was sie hätten bezahlen können wir
wirklich am anfang einfach umfragen
gemacht und gesagt ganz spontan wie viel
würdet ihr erhöhen können und daraufhin
haben wir antworten bekommen die bereits
erste zusagen ansatz haben nehmen können
und ja und das diskutieren wir einfach
ganz berlin diskutiert wie teuer darf
wohnen werden
und wem gehört die stadt